we're now going to look
and see how least squares can be used
to build tune or fit a classifier
so the way we'll do it it's actually
pretty straightforward
um what we're going to do is we're
simply going to do
standard least squares data fitting
where
the outcome is simply going to be a plus
or minus 1.
the number plus or minus one now
remember the actual outcome is either
always plus or minus one
uh so we'll build a model that just
targets that that's just standard
least squares uh data fitting now of
course what that means we're gonna call
that thing f
tilde not f hat the reason we're going
to call it f tilde is because what it
gives you
is a number whereas in fact f hat
must be plus or minus one right because
if you say does the patient have the
disease
you're not allowed to say you know
whatever uh plus point two or something
like that you have to say yes or no
um oh i should add there are methods for
classification where you guess a
probability
of something happening and that would
indeed be a number
okay so the idea here is uh
well by construction f tilde it should
be near plus one when y is one
and it should be near minus one when y
is minus one so that's that's what we're
gonna we're gonna construct such a thing
um and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take the sine of this now sine is
a mathematical function
that gives you this is equal to
plus 1 if f tilde of x
is bigger than or equal to 0 and minus 1
if f tilde of x is less than zero now
what i've done here is i have broken tie
which is when f tilde of x equals zero
uh by calling it plus one but it really
doesn't i mean you can
break it the other way if you like or
randomly it doesn't matter
um and you can even sort of think of a
couple of interesting things here right
like that uh you can certainly interpret
when f tilde is near one you would say
oh it's pretty confidence plus one
if it's near minus one it's pretty
confident it's minus 1.
if it's plus 0.01 it's basically saying
uh honestly i don't know if it's plus 1
or minus 1. but if you force me to guess
i would guess plus 1. so okay
um what we'll do is we'll look at an
example now uh of
uh of of this and we're gonna look at a
famous uh data set
it's the mnist data set uh
it's 70 000 images of
uh handwritten digits uh with some
pretty bad handwriting in there too
okay so these are 28 by 28 images of the
digits zero
uh to nine and it's about seventy
thousand about seventy thousand of them
um that's been divided into a training
set of 60 000 and a test set
um so x is a
uh it is a 494 vector
it's not 28 squared by the way because a
lot of the entries are just always zero
and therefore don't matter uh and we add
a constant
one um uh and and we get the
oh well there's only 493 pixels which
are ever nonzero
right so for example the the pixel at
the bottom left is
is always dark so it doesn't really
contribute
okay and we what we're going to do is
we're going to consider the problem
of guessing whether a handwritten digit
is 0 or not a 0. so it's going to be
plus 1 if it's 0
and minus one if it's not zero so if
it's one two three up to nine
but plus one if it's one so so we're
just we're just trying to we're just
trying to make something that will guess
if an image is a zero that's it
okay so
um here's the training set results uh
and the error rate uh is about 1.6
percent
so here is the confusion matrix for that
and you know
these were we can check a couple of
things we can say that oh yeah how about
that look at that that the number of of
true zeros was about six thousand
well okay that's not a sixty thousand
that's about one tenth makes sense
um and of
the six thousand zeros we got um
we got a little over five thousand uh
correctly
okay and we got uh 765 times
it was a zero and we said no it's not um
good news is that when the digit wasn't
a zero we got a whole lot of them right
and we didn't make too many errors we
didn't make too many false positives we
made 167 false positives
a false positive in this context means
that there's a digit it's not zero but
we look at it we go
we guess it's zero okay so and overall
the error rate which is this number
plus this number divided by the total
which is sixty thousand
it's one point six percent now when we
go to the test set which is a test set
of 10 000
we get about the same error rate and um
that's actually all as well right these
these numbers here um
these numbers here are approximately you
know
the same as these scaled by 1 6. that's
good
that means that we're not over overfit
and what it means is we can likely
just find a zero uh with an error rate
of about 1.6
on unseen images okay so and we can
guess that because the train and test
are very very close here
um by the way this sounds pretty good
it's not that good to tell you the truth
um you know so
people are down at a at a lower level
than that and
more advanced methods of machine
learning these days and even some of the
ones that we'll be able to look at later
in the class
will get you actually at or beyond human
performance
right so they can actually they'll do
better than people which is kind of cool
this one doesn't this is this is just
very elementary least squares
classification
so a very interesting thing to do here
is to look
at the distribution of the values of f
tilde of x i uh over the training set
okay and so this is what you get and
it's actually really cool
right so the red ones are the ones where
it was negative meaning it was a digit
one through nine
and the blue ones show what our value of
f tilde is
on the cases where it really was a zero
um and
you know remember when our our
classifier does this it makes a
threshold here right at zero and it says
if you're to the right of that
we're going to consider you a you know
positive which means zero
and if you're to the left we're going to
consider negative and that means you're
a digit one to nine
okay so this is uh this is how that
works and you can see a lot of stuff
there's a lot of blue over here that
that was our
maybe disconcertingly large
number of i guess those are false
negatives that's when we say nope that's
not a zero but it really is
okay so you can see that but you do see
a beautiful separation of the two
classes and that says we're really doing
something here
um so which is kind of cool
so here are the coefficients in the uh
in the classifier
so um a bunch of zero uh so on the
outside here
uh you see a whole bunch of pixels that
are like just zero
and that's because in fact um those
pixels are never zero in the images
so um so there there's a zero here um
but you can see all the others uh you
can see various things and
and we can even interpret it like it's
kind of weird like for example the fact
that these are negative
says that for those pixels um
having a bright spot in those pixels
basically you know i'm
anthropomorphizing this you know
basically very much reduces the
probability
that that handwritten digit is a zero um
here there's some kind of distributed
things you can actually sort of see
visually uh kind of a an annulus here
where it's
it's it's kind of red and that says
pixels that
land you know when you have when you
have a you know
a white spot in those in that region
it's more likely to be a zero than not
um
i mean from some points of view when you
see this it's hard to imagine that this
really
does give you like a 1.6 error rate
on things you haven't seen but it does
it's super simple
um
one one more topic uh relating
to to uh well classification in general
but in particularly squares
classification is this
we have been using a threshold here
now let's go back a couple of zero right
um
but your eyeball might want to do
something weird like say you know what
let's use this threshold
right and that threshold is going to
very much reduce the number of our false
negatives it's going to increase the
number of our false positives
but you know then we'll get them kind of
maybe on the same scale or something
like that so
this is the idea of just switching the
threshold from zero so what we would do
is we'd choose a number alpha and we're
going to say that f of
x f hat of x that's our actual guess
like minus one or plus one
is plus one if you're bigger than alpha
and minus one if you're less than alpha
so alpha equals zero we recover exactly
what we had before
and alpha's called the decision
threshold i mean for obvious reasons
um now for positive alpha uh
what happens is the false positive rate
is you know roughly speaking when alpha
is positive
you are more reticent i am again
anthropomorphizing you are more reticent
to guess plus one well that means you're
gonna make uh
you're gonna make less false positives
because
there'll be something where it's it's
not positive you don't know it of course
and you'll be less likely to announce
that that's a plus one
um but some will be the true positive
rate because also
some of the ones that are true positives
you'll now look at and go yeah it was
bigger than zero but it's not bigger
than alpha so i think it's minus one
okay now when you vary
alpha and you make a you make a
trade-off curve of the true positive
versus the
false positive rates you get a strange
thing called the
receiver operating characteristic or roc
curve
and it is drawn in other uh in other
ways um
but this is this is the basic idea now
i'll say a little bit about
um the history of it it's it's a term
from world war ii
and it refers to uh either sonar most
likely or radar
and so the basic idea was to try to
figure out you know
you know is there an enemy ship you know
at uh out at uh
22 kilometers in that direction right
you'd be getting some
uh you'd be getting some sonar readings
and then
you would just yes i mean that's what
this is about
um okay so that's the origin of receiver
operating characteristic
but it's been taken up and it's used
universally in statistics machine
learning
uh everyone would know what an roc curve
is
so to give a rough idea of what an roc
curve is or how this works
what we do here is here i have displaced
i've set alpha equals i don't know 0.2
and what that means is
all of these i'm going to
i'm going to classify as plus 1. and
that's good because they're all plus 1.
notice that you know the red
distribution down here i'm going to have
an extreme
when alpha is 0.2 i'm going to have a
really low
uh error uh error on on my
um on things that are negative that i
think are positive so false positives is
going to be
super low on the other hand look at all
these over here
those your my false positive rate um
is is is going to be uh sorry this is
the false positive the true positive
rate is also going to be
much lower so um so here it is plotted
where we plot alpha and all let me show
you what's happening here is when you
imagine if i put a dashed curve there
that's minus
0.5 sorry 0.5 there
what we're doing is the total number of
red
points to the left tells me that it
tells me
uh the number of negative ones that i uh
i correctly nail as negative the ones to
the right
of that thing are errors so this would
be error
same for the blue except you switch the
orientation so you get curves that look
like this
right and um here's zero right
and let me remind you what you want uh
you want the
uh red curve to be small and you want
the blue curve to be high
okay um oh and you can see here that the
total error that's the simple
uh metric that just looks at one one
thing is
uh you can see that actually that you
know could argue for taking uh
you know something like what i drew
alpha equals you know minus
0.3 or something like that and that
would be a good threshold for this
so this is an example of a our roc
analysis this is the kind of curve that
you usually get
and this shows false positive rate um so
in these curves uh left is good
right and high is good right so
that's the best you could possibly do
right there that says that your false
positive rate is zero and your true
positive rate is
one right when something is when
something is negative
when an example is negative you guess
it's negative always
when something is positive you guess is
positive always so this is an roc curve
um and it's something you know people
would talk about and things like that
and a reasonable question would be
what value of alpha should i take right
that is subjective
and the answer to that depends on the
application and it depends on what are
the relative costs of making the two
types of errors
like uh what you know what is the
relative cost of a false positive versus
a false negative
right so that's that's kind of the idea
so and that's not anything
i mean no math can tell you that right
and the data can't tell you that
that something has to come from the
application so if you say
you know we can't have too many false
positives because you know if there's
too many false positives after all
people are going to ignore the alarm
that that's a typical thing that might
happen or you'd say
false negatives are really bad because
if we don't catch this and treat that
disease
the outcome is very poor so that would
be something where a false negative
would be a very bad thing
right it could also be that you have
another test that's more powerful
and you know all you want to do you skew
it towards um
in the conservative direction so that if
it comes up positive it doesn't mean
that you
are certain the person has the disease
it means let's schedule some more
uh let's let's schedule some more tests
and and see what's happening
okay so um let me tell you just a few
more things
about this um you will learn in other
courses how to do uh classification
like this um you probably won't see
least squares classification
uh because in fact there are better ways
to do it which don't involve
least squares but they're extremely
similar i think you'll when you see
those things
maybe you've already seen them but when
you see them you'll see that they
actually do
work better but they're very similar in
spirit everything else is the same
roc curve everything else makes perfect
sense actually even the modern form
can be identical so you'll see you'll
see better ways to do this using other
other methods um uh that's especially
true
for the example with the digits right
that digi those things uh
maybe for five eight years now uh
if there are other methods not based on
least squares
that give stunning uh stunning results
in test
of course i would never tell you
anything about the training in in
testing
those have been incredibly successful
they beat people by the way
which is kind of weird because you think
how could a how can a machine
i don't know how how could some crazy
algorithm that looks at
pixels actually beat a human being and
the answer is
they do um so so in fact you might you
know
all i'm doing here is saying this is an
example of least squares uh
to be perfectly honest these are not bad
classifiers right i mean there are worse
classifiers than these they
they actually work okay it's the right
way to say it and they're pretty
simple uh so i think that's why we've uh
we've covered them
and you know it's also just good for
people for you to know
about what is a classifier and now that
you know least squares you can
you can come up with a classifier in
other courses you're going to learn more
about more sophisticated classifiers but
this is not a bad start
at all